who underwrites this whole series and also thanks
to the Santa Fe reporter and the
lensic for their support thank
you so um I'm I've been given the great
honor of introducing radika nagpal who's
long been one of my my own intellectual heroes
in the field of complex systems um rodica is
currently the Augustine professor in engineering
at Princeton and she's really had a long career
of doing Cutting Edge research on biologically
inspired Compu Computing and swarm robotics which
you'll hear more about from her and collective
intelligence in general in biological and and
in AI systems and she's also in in addition to
her academic career she's an entrepreneur she
co-founded a company called root robotics which
does educational robotics and rodic has received
many awards for her research way too many to
list here but I'll mention two in 2014 she was
named by the journal Nature as one of the top
10 influential scientists and Engineers of that
year and in 2021 she was named by Newsweek
magazine as one of America's 50 greatest
disruptors and I'll take that disruptors is a
large complement in the tech World okay
so tonight she'll tell us about her very
disrupt research on Collective behavior
and Robotics let's welcome rpal thank
you thanks thanks so much for having me here um I
don't know about the disruptive part but today I
wanted to tell you some stories of of Science and
maybe even just AI as a kind of Investigation of
science uh and I'm calling it taming the Swarm so
uh I'm a computer scientist and also a roboticist
and the area and theme that I study is collective
intelligence as Melanie mentioned um which is how
we can have large numbers of individuals with
maybe simple and local interacting rules that
cooperate to achieve globally complex Behavior
so what does it mean for a computer scientist and
a roboticist to study uh collective intelligence
well some days great days it looks something like
this so this is me on my 45th birthday uh trekking
10 miles a day 90° weather 100% humidity in Panama
at the Smithsonian tropical Institute to study
army ants and this is actually going to be the
subject of my talk today so I hope you like ants
um but army ants are this spectacular example of
collective intelligence um millions of them work
together without any leaders in charge and they
build their entire nest out of their bodies they
even create these crazy bridge-like structures
to get over terrain that they don't like and
they're constantly working together to change
their environment to work for them but lots of
other things can also be considered collective
intelligence I like to think of cells as having
collective intelligence um cells with identical
DNA cooperate to create complex structures from
fruit fly to starfish to ourselves you can also
think of um collective intelligence as operating
a really large scale so these are examples of
termite Mounds that can be anywhere from 2
to 10 m high and in fact they're created by
insects that are centimeter scale um in their
size so it's little individuals creating this
tremendous skyscrapers full of internal structure
and of course who can forget bird flocks and uh
fish schools and herds of Bison we see groups
navigate in nature moving together uh moving
around obstacles sometimes even creating these
beautiful displays uh out of themselves so I CH
just showed you examples of these Collective
uh systems and I think that these systems are
fascinating to pretty much all of us when we
observe them and I think one of the things that
that makes it fascinating intuitively is that
each individual is just so tiny compared to the
massive phenomenon that they are creating and so
it kind of boggles the Mind how how the group can
function when each individual must be only able
to see limited things in its environment and yet
not know what's going on at the other edge of the
Swarm but somehow the system is coordinating so
well and it's coordinating so well that we often
just even forget that there are individuals we
just think of this as one entity it's a school
it's a swarm it moved L it moved right it's a it
because we don't even think of the individuals as
exist ing separately so that to me is always just
amazing and striking it's kind of a intelligence
that is emerging at the collective level but we
also actually do know some things about the
algorithms or the mechanisms by which this
collective intelligence comes uh together and in
these examples it actually really is remarkable
that um we know that there are actually no
leaders supervising these groups instead
somehow this incredible collective intelligence
is emerging from individuals interacting with
other individuals using relatively simple rules
but then somehow those simple rules when run by
this very very large decentralized group are
creating something that from the outside looks
like Collective behavior and it's a kind of
self-organization that of course feels both
mysterious but also is just incredibly powerful
so of course these systems exist in nature and we
can study them uh as biologists but we can also
ask about making them so what would it mean to
create our own artificial collectives based on
these same principles so in AI we often think of
natural intelligence as a model for systems that
we might be able to create and maybe we create
these systems to solve applications but sometimes
we also build systems just to probe the nature of
intelligence do we understand the principles
by which intelligence arises and a lot of AI
focus focuses maybe not un not surprisingly on
human intelligence copying and understanding what
humans do but we could also think of copying what
ant colonies do so what for example what would it
mean if we could create a colony of robots that
did all of the things that ant colonies do so
for example explore their territory forage and
collect food maybe even just build their nest or
their structure so in the early 1990s uh a young
researcher pondered this question um Maya mataric
uh grew up in the former Yugoslavia she did her
undergrad at the University of Kansas and then
came to MIT for PhD in robotics and she became
um from the work that she did during her PhD and
then later as a professor she became one of the
pioneers of the field that is now known as swarm
robotics so she asked the question um can we build
robots that cooperate the way ant colonies uh do
and in order to um that cooperate the way ant
colonies do without any leaders so purely through
interactions between individuals and so not only
did she create algorithms and programming models
to make this happen she actually also created
one of the first robots swarms that operated on
these principles so here you can see a a picture
of that swarm that was in 19 1993 uh there were
20 robots that would work together to explore
their Arena they would find food which was like
these orange pucks and stack them and they could
even work together to push obstacles out of the
way like if you put a box in front of their nest
or something like that and in this process she
showed that we could actually create cooperation
um with robots that were actually quite simple
in their individual capabilities but as a group
could do really remarkable things um many people
were inspired by uh Maya mataric work um so was
I I was a much younger researcher at MIT many
many years later and I was super inspired both
by this work and also by Maya herself so just
a little bit about me I grew up in a small town
uh called amiter in India and uh I have to admit
that I hated ants in fact I'm pretty sure I hated
all insects at that point um I also didn't know
a whole lot about science and engineering and I
didn't really have any female role models so it
was actually only after I began College um that I
learned all of these things in fact my goal at in
joining College was very simple it was to get a
job that would give me the Financial Freedom so
that I could make my own decisions but while I
was in college I started to discover that I like
to build things and I like to program um and I
started to get excited about this area so really
it was actually quite late in my life though
that I maybe in my mid-30s that I essentially
rediscovered Robotics and started to become
enamored uh with ants and so in my group we've
actually build a lot of different robot swarms
that are inspired uh by different kinds of animals
so we've done things inspired by fish we've done
things inspired by bees uh we've done things
inspired by termites that build um but today I'm
really going to talk about uh something inspired
by ants similar to what Maya was thinking about
at that time how can ants Inspire us to make robot
colonies and so I'm going to tell you a story
um about one about a project in my group where
we were inspired by the spectacular collective
intelligence of army ants and this will be the
story of Five People three roboticists and two
biologists who went to Panama in March 2016 to
observe and experiment with this uh to observe
this amazing system and its natural habitat all
right so I just want to start with a with a little
video so um you saw a little bit of this before
already but armi ants are truly the queens of self
assembly and reconfiguration and together with
other ants species like fire ants and Weaver ants
um they self-assemble structures out of their own
body on demand so they're constantly forming and
unform struct structures uh to solve problems in
their environment because they're nomadic they
actually self assemble their whole nest out of
their body so they migrate every fortn night and
then when they migrate to a new place they just
create recreate their nest and they also create
these crazy Bridge structures to get over rough
terrain that they don't like um and even though
the bridges might get damaged or destroyed by
humans ikaa me uh they can actually repair it just
within a a minute or two in fact we accidentally
stepped on one of the nests and we actually
saw a nest self-repair itself so it's pretty
crazy so we still don't fully understand how these
systems work but we can create artificial setups
to try to reverse engineer or try to understand
what uh is happening with these systems and so
we're beginning to learn some of the principles
for me I'm also just really amazed at looking at
these systems closeup I hope this doesn't totally
creep you out but these are ants crawling all over
other ants that are like linked to each other it's
just an amazing system this leaving breathing kind
of tissue it almost looks like a cell tissue
in the way that they function and so somehow
they are both organisms but then also materials
and collectives in this strange way and for me I
found that just incredibly uh fascinating okay
so why do armi ants make bridges well it turns
out they make bridges for reasons that we can
all I think relate to so maybe you've been to
a park where there's a a sort of sidewalk you're
supposed to walk on and it goes kind of roundabout
way but later on you start noticing people just
cut across and then people have cut across so much
that like the grass has started to be removed so
now there's a cut through path so somebody's made
like a shortcut in the system we make a lot of
shortcuts in life well the army ants do this too
but it's a little bit weirder so this is a picture
that you saw earlier where I broke the bridge and
what you see here I can't know if you can see a
they can actually go this long path so they can go
the long way around but they don't want to which
is why they actually create this shortcut Bridge
across and so uh my colleague Simone Garnier
and his team uh had worked on this before they
noticed that a lot of times these Bridges were in
situations where there was like a V or a detour
and the bridges were actually a shortcut so using
this idea they studied some Natural Bridges but
then they also created an artificial uh detour
so this thing that you see on the left is a is
a white detour and they're tricking the army ants
to go on this detour and then they can change the
angle of the detour so they can make it a really
um sort of flat one or really sort of one where
you kind of want to cross already and with this
they started to study what were the conditions
under which armi ants make bridges and they made
some really interesting uh discoveries one of
the first discoveries was that if that it really
depended on traffic so if there weren't a lot of
ants on on this path then no Bridges would form
the ants would just happily take the long uh the
long way around but if the traffic got heavy and
there was congestion then all of a sudden these
Bridges would start forming and even weirder is
that the width of the bridge was proportional to
the traffic so the more traffic you had the bigger
Bridge you got and then if you stop the traffic or
you the traffic died out or in some cases they
just diverted it then this bridge would kind of
get up and leave it would just disassemble and so
what you would see is the the ants on the edge of
the bridge we kind of leave first then the next
ones then the next ones kind of like when you
put a sugar cube in water and it dissolves you
basically see the bridge dissolved so I actually
show you some videos where you can see this too
so it's really really cool so this is actually
kind of a crazy observation right that you have
this amazing adaptive self assembly so uh for me
I thought like wow this is the best sustainable
architecture ever you know you could get right
when you need it stuff grows to meet your need
when you don't need it it shrinks and goes away
and you always have like exactly the right size
I mean I wish the George Washington Bridge work
this way right it's like when on Peak traffic
suddenly it gets really wide and like there's
no congestion and then uh when there's nobody
on it it just shrinks and you can just see the
river beautifully without anything in your way
but this is essentially what the army ants are
doing so they're making these bridges that are
not only shortcuts but really really adaptive
shortcuts and they're temporary so now we know
what they do globally but of course it's much
harder to reverse engineer is an ant thinking so
what what makes an ant decide to be part of the
bridge or decide to even start a bridge and so we
don't at all know the answer to that but there was
a a really interesting hypothesis about how this
might occur and the hypothesis is that it could
be from a very very simple ant Behavior so imagine
for a moment that you are an ant and what you do
is normally you just you're just walking along
the path and you happily walk along um but then
you start to experience congestion and so in this
case congestion is that other people are actually
climbing over you so you're getting stepped on and
this is your form of congestion and so if you're
getting stepped on you decide okay I'm not going
to walk anymore I'm just going to be stationary
and I'm going to become part of the bridge and I'm
going to let people walk over me which of course
none of us would really want to do but the answer
very strong and actually like physically very
different from us so you stop and you become a
bridge and you let people walk over you or you'll
let other ants walk over you and then similarly
maybe you've been sitting around for a while
and nobody has walked on you for a while and then
you decide okay well I don't need to be a bridge
anymore and I can leave so that's the bottom so
we think of this as a two-state machine you're
in a walking state or a bridge State and there's a
transition so if I'm in Walking State I turn into
a bridge if someone walks on me I'm in Bridge
State I go back to walking if nobody is walking
on me so it's really simple so why would this
arise why would this create the right behavior
and there's a little bit of like a trick in this
piece a piece that we don't fully understand so
the idea is that if there's no traffic or very
little then everybody's walking but if there's
suddenly congestion then a lot of individuals are
getting walked on so suddenly they become part of
the bridge but by becoming part of the bridge they
actually create new territory to walk over which
actually relieves congestion so now no more
answer are experiencing congestion and that's
why the bridge stops growing so I hopefully
that makes sense it's like there's congestion
you make a bridge but then the bridge fixes the
congestion and then everything just stabilizes so
we call these kind of algorithms self-stabilizing
they they start and then something within them
causes them to decide when enough is enough and
then of course if the traffic goes away then the
second part of the bridge can the second part
of the state machine can work which is that the
individuals in the bridge now are no longer exper
experiencing congestion so they can start getting
up and going away and in this way the bridge
can constantly be just the right size to make
congestion go to make the congestion zero this is
the hypothesis so it's still really hard to prove
that but it is a really attractive way to think
about how a very simple ant Behavior could result
in something that is globally so smart so this was
sort of the observation from Simone's group the
second observation that I want to make actually
is is something that biologists typically take for
granted but for engineers like myself is a little
bit harder to think about and that is that the
the bridge doesn't look like human Bridges human
Bridges we make them out of trusses and lates and
very regular and the reason we do that is because
that provides material strength trusses are really
strong so when you think have things make made
out of triangles that's a really strong way of
building things and it means that your Bridge can
last for really long and you haven't wasted a lot
of material they're also really easy to analyze
but these Bridges look nothing like that these are
more organic looking we call them amorphous but I
think most of us would call them organic there's
just a lot of ants and they're just attached all
over the place to each other so it looks super
messy and clearly is using many more ants than you
need but the interesting thing in this method is
that you can make bridges really fast because
nobody has to attach to anyone very precisely
so the ants are just coming and grabbing on to
each other in all different ways and there's no
Precision so this this really fast construction
but messy construction and then the other thing
is that it's also kind of compliant so the ants
and their legs they're not rigid like a truss a
truss is to be like a perfect size but here this
thing can kind of deal with some vibrations and
the messiness of the environment so it's both uh
soft and also messy so it turns out that that of
course most bridges that we think of are not like
that or most construction we don't do it this way
but there is actually one case where as people we
do construct in the same way and it's when people
build out of sandbags so if you have to build
a levy in a flood situation you need a lot of
people to build really fast and we don't have
time to Train everybody to make you an expert
Builder so we need a material that's easy to use
that's compliant so sandbags you can kind of put
them on each other and they'll just kind of like
mush together and so they're soft and they're
compliant and now you can have lots of people
build really fast and the point of the structure
is to be temporary so interestingly enough we also
have an example when we want to build really fast
temporary structures we actually use a method that
is closer to army ants than when we want to build
structures that live for a long time so maybe
that's one reason the structures look this way
is that these are structures that they're forming
and unform ing constantly in their environment is
not a long-term commitment it's a short-term need
that's being solved through self assembly so army
ants are cool I hope I've convinced you of that uh
wouldn't robots be cooler so imagine that we could
create uh a robot Colony inspired by army ants
so it would do all of the things that the nerd
herd did so it could explore the environment maybe
it could collect materials in the environment and
bring it uh to one place so it could forage and
explore but then if it experienced a different
difficult terrain then maybe it can self assemble
a bridge or a ramp or a or a chain or a tower to
get through whatever problem it experienced in
its environment maybe it could self assemble a
shelter to prevent some things from being rained
on or uh protect things from from the elements and
this kind of self- assembly would be then all
of a sudden like the army ants so in my group
we were really inspired by this of course self
assembling robots that could do this are still
in the realm of Science Fiction so please do
not expect that we're actually going do I'm
not going to show you robots that can do all of
these things but for us experimenting with these
ideas is also a way of understanding natural
intelligence so the two observations I gave
you are the two observations that this project
was based on and I should say that this project
was led by Melinda Mali who did her PhD uh in
my group and is now uh visiting faculty at and
Melinda's Vision was that we would create a new
uh robotic system and it would be called aceton
robotica so adding a species into the aceton
genus um and the two things we would look at
were can we design soft robots that can climb over
each other and form these organic structures and
what is it what do we get if we have soft robots
um what do this what does that give us over rigid
robots that make trusses uh can we get some of
the same uh interesting properties and the second
one was can we design rules for self assembly uh
similar to the Army ant so if we take the Army
ant Rule and we simulate it for these robots
or we simulate it for ants would we actually
recover the hypotheses that the biologists had
put put before us does it really result in the
kind of self-stabilizing behavior so basically
making robots and experimenting with rules and
so that's what uh Melinda Mali did so I'm going
to start by showing you um her robots and the
first caveat is the robots don't look like ants
so when we experiment with biological hypotheses
we don't always copy everything ants are actually
really really complicated and I there are groups
that are trying to copy ants that are six-legged
and have antennas and have all these sensors I am
not capable of that so in our group we actually
made a different kind of robot uh that's maybe
more inspired by slugs and caterpillars uh and
maybe even just like by nothing biological at
all but it still has the same properties of soft
and organic self assembly so I'm going to show you
a video sort of illustrating this robot first
all right so here you can see Melinda and you
can see her robot in its natural habitat um which
is also very green and the robot has two legs and
a soft body and it has two cables so when you
pull one cable and you release the other cable
the robot is able to flip its body over and
bend it so you can think of this as a puppet
where you're like pulling the strings and moving
the body with these um with these strings and so
the way this robot moves is it flips itself over
and then when its foot hits something it grabs and
then it flips its body over and you can think of
the foot as essentially searching for something to
grab onto and in this way it can actually climb
and move in many different orientations I don't
know if this will be as impressive to you but it's
actually really hard to make climbing robots that
transition from one orientation to another so we
were super excited that we could make this robot
do these things and it's really important that
the body be soft because as you go through these
different transitions the body is actually really
compliant it gets compressed or stretches a little
and so it takes away some of the uncertainty in
the system and um we have sensors in the feet so
they can detect when they're touching something
but the other piece is gripping so how does the
robot grip onto something strongly enough that it
can flip its whole body over and then grip again
so here Melinda was inspired by the fact that ants
have microspines and tarsel hooks that allow them
to grab into textured surfaces and so we created
grippers that can uh grip into textured surfaces
so they have these little cork screws which you'll
see in a second and we turn the cork screws and
they can grab into things like foam or carpet or
velcro um by sort of spiraling in and grabbing
onto things and then when we want to let go we
spiral the other way and kind of come out of the
system and you can actually make really strong
connections with this surprisingly um but then
we covered the robots in texture itself so now not
only can the robot climb over the environment it
can also climb over other robots so here you can
see it climbing uh over another stationary robot
all right and hopefully it'll be able to climb
over multiple robots so here you can see uh you
can also see that it's not exactly reliable um
got a little CAU there but we can actually make
pretty interesting structures like can levers and
chains with this okay so we can grab we can climb
but the next piece of it puzzle was that ants
could detect when somebody was walking over them
so how do our robots detect if they're being
walked over so we decided to use vibration so
the robots actually create vibrations and so when
they step on someone else you feel it because you
feel their vibrations and insects use this idea
of stridulation which is communicating through
vibration so we use that idea so here you see two
robots and the top robot uh ends up climbing over
the bottom robot and when the bottom robot feels
that it's being walked on because it detects us
through the vibration it decides to go into Bridge
and just stay there and let the other robot climb
over it so you can see that here and then it
leaves Bridge State but then it tries to escape
our experiment um so these robots are still pretty
limited um for example even though we're moving
Against Gravity they're still only in 2D uh but
if you had three strings and with a lot more work
we could potentially make them move in different
ways so we're still considering different ways of
thinking about the these soft robotss but we made
two of them and we're were able to illustrate the
basic idea which is still pretty far from from
the vision okay so we have two robots so how do
we experiment with rules well to experiment with
rules we might need hundreds of robots and that's
where simulation comes in and so um we created
a simulation or essentially an animation well
a simulation is a better word for it um and I'll
just explain the simulation a little bit here so
at the top are these small little robots uh we
just modeling them as two feet and they'll move
with flipping and we created an environment that
was very similar to what Simone and his colleagues
had looked at which is that there's a v detour
so you'll will the robots can just flip and walk
down this uh V detour but if they collide with
each other or get stepped on then they turn into
Bridge State and when they turn into Bridge State
they turn into that lighter color so you can sort
of see that they've changed state by this light
color um and I think that was that those were the
things I wanted to tell you about the simulation
and then we simulated with different conditions so
what happens in low traffic what happens in high
traffic what happens if we stop the traffic uh and
so I'll show you a video of this but a good way
to think of this is uh as a video game this is a
video game kind of like the Lemmings you will see
Lemmings moving along this track all right so here
are little Lemmings and they're flipping around
and and moving and this is sort of low traffic so
we did have a collision and a little Bridge formed
but once the bridge formed there's actually no
more collisions so the traffic has stabilized the
any congestion is gone uh with this little bridge
now we create some more traffic you can see that
the robots are really close to each other so now
they're like bumping into each other along the way
so we start to form this bridge uh as the bridge
forms it does smooth out the traffic but you can
see the bridge is still forming here um and every
time there's a collision and now all of a sudden
we have a pretty decent Bridge Okay and somebody's
trapped okay so now we sto the traffic and it's
really fun to see so we've stopped the traffic so
now individuals in the bridge are free to leave of
course you're not exactly free to leave if you're
stuck at the bottom so individuals suddenly decide
that they're leaving and they climb over others
who then can't leave because they keep getting
climbed over um So eventually that poor one at
the top will get a chance to leave but for now
it's just stuck there and leave and we did have
some cases of Deadlock which I we never observed
with the ants but I think those two robots stay
there forever all right so it turns out that
this algorithm works for lots of different
things you can make ramps you can make um sort
of staircases so it's not actually specific to
making a bridge across a v it can make a bridge
across complex terrains and in some recent work
Linda and some of her new students showed that you
could even um close gaps with it so in this case
it's an algorithm that's similar um every time
you get stepped on you turn into a bridge but
this allows you to make a can lever to actually
reach the other uh the other part and weer ants
actually do this quite a bit they're able to
make uh Canal levers like this across different
branches so we were able to replicate a lot of the
results that the biologist believe were true from
this from this Rule and we did it with something
that doesn't even look like ants it's actually a
robot it just gives you this sense of like maybe
these ideas might be really General so in low
traffic you get no um bridge in medium traffic
you get kind of small bridges in high traffic
you get big Bridges and then if the traffic is
really really high you get essentially a pileup
and of course we know what a pileup looks like but
actually they observed pileups with the ants as
well so it it turned out this was something that
had been observed okay so what one of the other
things we can do with this kind of simulation
is we can create something that we call a phase
space maybe some of you already have have heard of
spa phase space but in case you haven't the idea
is that I'm going to create a grid and on the left
of the Grid or on the vertical axis is the traffic
flow so at the top the traffic is really the flow
is really low and at the bottom the flow is really
high so we're thinking of flow on this side
and then in the horizontal axis we're thinking
about the terrain so there at the left is like a
really narrow terrain that's like really annoying
everyone's going to collide into everyone and on
the right is a train that's so wide it might as
well have been flat so we have these two axes and
then we do a bunch of simulations to fill in all
of the boxes in this two-dimensional space and we
can we think of this as sort of the phase space
like what are the different parameters and what
are the behaviors that we'll see so if you think
about this uh bottom left corner this is actually
the worst case scenario super congested there's
really really high traffic and there's a really
narrow Gap so it's the most congested region and
then the upper right is like the easiest problem
so there's very little traffic and the terrain is
practically flat so we can show in this system a
really nice phase space So at the bottom left here
there's stable Bridge formation and the bridge is
proportional to the difficulty of the problem so
if it's really high traffic or really really small
Gap then we get a bigger bridge and in the upper
right corner there no bridges are forming at all
so it never makes a mistake and forms a bridge in
the upper side and then between those two regions
there's kind of this weird stochastic region where
sometimes you get a bridge and sometimes you don't
it kind of depends on random fluctuations whether
or not you get a bridge but they're pretty small
Bridges no matter what okay so these phase spaces
are actually really common um throughout science
and it allowed us to think about something that
maybe hadn't occurred to us before and that is a
very simil phase face is seen for things that are
not living and we call this idea jamming so ants
are actually behaving like materials so jamming
is something that all of us are actually super
familiar with so for anyone here actually I'm
assuming everybody has done this but you have a
a bag of rice and you have a funnel and you pour
the rice through the funnel right now technically
the rice are really small and the funnel opening
is open but nevertheless jams form you're pouring
and the thing gets jammed just gets stuck and what
happens is the rice form this little like Bridge
likee structure and all of a sudden this whole
system can get stuck together and we call this
a jam but we also know that if you pour the rice
really slowly it doesn't it Jam if you try to pour
the rice really fast it jams and so the rice is
the flow or the traffic so if you have really
low traffic you don't Jam if you do it really
fast then it jams and the size of your funnel is
essentially the Gap so if I have a funnel that's
really tiny I have to pour the rice really really
slowly whereas if I have a funnel that's really
big I can pour the rice really fast and be okay
and so in fact this whole phase space of bridges
as jams and no Bridges as not jamming is actually
a really similar behavior and I find this really
interesting that at one level of course we know
that the ants are organisms they're living and
breathing in full um fully living creatures and
yet there are times that they are behaving pretty
much almost seemingly indistinguishable from
things that are not living uh and just exploiting
the physics of their bodies and there's a lot
of work where people are studying ants uh both
as especially in these large collectives both as
materials but also as living organisms that have
evolved ways of explo exploiting the physics
of their own bodies all right so coming back
to uh I want to tell you one more thing about um
army ants and I did not at all keep track of time
okay um want to tell you one more thing about army
ants um and this is work done by uh my colleague
Helen mccu who actually spent a lot of time here
in Santa Fe uh she's a she was a James McDonald
fellow and worked with the Santa Fe Institute
um and now she's a lecturer at toughs so Helen
was another member of this group that went to uh
went to Panama and uh Helen spent three months
there conducting experiments uh on army ants
so Simone and his group had noticed that not
only could army ants make these shortcut Bridges
across V's they actually sometimes had these like
long suspension bridges and they were not sure
how these suspension bridges were coming apart
but they started to do some experiments and they
realized that not only could the ants make these
pretty long Bridges out of their own bodies they
could even repair them so even as you perturbed
it they could actually fix the bridge in real time
so based on these early observations Helen decided
to design an experiment uh to test how robust
are are these kinds of behaviors how much how
big a suspension bridge can you make what kind
of prod ations can it uh can it do and so you
can see Helen sitting next to the apparatus so
what she had to do was trick the ants you kind
of make a ramp of leaves on both sides and you
trick the army ants to go over this apparatus
and so once the army ants are going over this
apparatus they're fine they treat it as part of
their Trail they don't really care but then you
start making their life hard which is that you
start introducing these gaps and what Helen did is
she just sort of they're they're walking over it
but she she's just creating a gra that Gap that's
increasing with time so I'm going to show you a
sped up video of what that looks like um and you
just have to sort of imagine that it's it's that
little section uh that she's looking at there
okay so here's a video of this happening it's
sped up so every 30 seconds she's increasing the
Gap by 1 millimeter so in the beginning the ants
were having a great time they were walking across
this thing no problems now it's like kind of hard
to get across so you see them forming a bridge uh
in real time to get across and as she increases
it more ants are joining into this bridge so the
bridge is actually lengthening as we create this
system so it keeps getting longer and longer and
longer and she does this until it's about 3 cm
but then she tricks them she starts to shorten
the Gap so now it's coming closer and you can
see sometimes it breaks but interestingly as
she shortens it some of the ants are leaving
so now now they're actually decreasing the size
of the uh of this and so we're doing this like
every half minute so they're very actually quite
quick at in at doing this and yes the last ant
does leave but but it's actually a little scary
she kept squishing it and like didn't really want
to kill it but we were trying to stick with the
protocol but they are very squishable so it did it
did finally leave all right so you can see Helen
there these are really difficult experiments to
do because unlike experiments um that we can do
in the lab here first you have to track 10 miles
a day and the army ants are nomadic which means
we actually spend a good part of the day finding
them I like where the heck are you setting up camp
so you go you find them and then you have to carry
everything with you all your cameras the umbrella
to like deal with the the amazing lighting uh and
and all of the apparatus and everything so you're
carrying this enormous backpack while sweating
like crazy uh and trying to find the Army ends
and when you do then you have maybe a couple
of hours to quickly do set this up do all of the
experiments all right so I showed you one example
I'll show you another video from this because this
one got became viral at some point because it was
really quite funny so here you could see there's
so much traffic that the ANS just like fell over
and so there's this huge pile it's almost like
like spilling milk but then they form a bridge
and you'll see the remarkable thing is that all of
the spilled ants down there actually climb back up
and so that whole part actually dissolves and this
was barely five minutes where you couldn't even
tell that anything had happened anymore we have
another video from like an iPhone where all of us
are screaming oh my God are they dissolving what's
happening um but it's really remarkable these ants
are both uh assembling and dis assembling and
repairing Bridges all in real time at the same
time so the question is could this Behavior also
be explained by the same hypothesis so uh or by
the same ant Behavior so one way to think about it
is um just imagine that as we stretch the bridges
uh the bridge gets harder to walk on because now
everyone's stretch and so you have nobody to stand
on and maybe that causes congestion which causes
indiv ual to join the bridge so as we stretch
we basically worsen the bridge by worsening the
bridge we create congestion by creating congestion
we cause ants to join the bridge thereby making
the bridge better and lengthening it and then the
opposite is when we decrease the Gap the bridge
becomes slack and so now they're ants at the
bottom that are no longer being walked on and so
they get up and leave and so in this way there are
both ants being added and ants being moved and so
in this way you have a bridge that essentially is
maintain maintaining its tension so if I stretch
it it adds more material to become less tense if
I slack it it takes away more material to come
back to the same tension and there is another
system that actually does this and that's cells
during wound repair so in wound repair um your
epithelial cells or your your skin cells or your
lining cells they form these tissue sheets and
it's been shown that if you stretch those sheets
the cells actually interpret that as a reason to
divide and so they divide uh if you stretch and
so that's one way to achieve wound repair but if
you slack them then they actually kill off some of
the cells and so the tissue can actually maintain
a correct density at all times by constantly
growing cells or killing cells and in this case
instead we're we're maintaining a constant density
so it turned out that this system also has a kind
of close to constant density by either adding ants
or removing ants so we're not killing anybody in
this case but we are or or reproducing in real
time but we are adding and removing material to
do this so this was really cool uh and we thought
it was really interesting and then Helen observed
something else that was really uh surprising to us
and that's historis so historis is this idea that
systems have memory after things happen to them
the best way that I under the way that I usually
understand historis is thinking about a rubber
band if you have a perfect rubber band you stretch
it and you release it and it always is the same
so you stretch it and then you bring it back and
it's the same but a lot of rubber bands don't do
that you stretch it and you bring it back and it's
slack so somehow in the process of stretching it
you deformed it in some way that stayed permanent
so that the next time you came to the original
conditions it doesn't look the same it has a
memory of things that happened in the past and
we think of that as as history say so what Helen
observed is that the system actually exhibited
hysteresis so um you could think of the red line
as the part where we're sort of stretching the
rubber band and so on the horizontal axis is the
number of ants or like the volume of the bridge
but you can just think of number of ants in the
bridge and on the x axis or the wait that was
the vertical axis sorry I can do this vertical
axis and then the horizontal axis is the gap how
much we stretched it so as she's stretching it
there's a certain number of ants in it but then
when she contracts it back the number of ants are
different in it so it's actually like much more
slack there are too many ants in it so it really
is like the rubber band that you stretch and then
when you came back it didn't quite go back to its
shape if this was a perfect rubber band then the
blue and the red lines would be right on top of
each other and so what Helen found is no matter
how many different colonies and experiments she
did she always had this the same result and this
was not something we were looking for so why would
you want hysteresis it sounds like a bad idea
right it's like this is we always think of this
is bad when we have rubber bands but actually
hysteresis is a really important principle for
engineering and we use it very deliberately so
one example where we use it is in a thermostat
so imagine that you set your thermostat to 72
degrees I guess I'm picking the number I like
so I like 72 degrees so I set my thermostat to 72
de and if it's above 72° then it needs to turn on
the air conditioning and if it's below 72 degre
it needs to turn on the heater so now imagine
that the temperature is 71.8 so it's like ah turn
on the heater and then next moment it's like 72.5
and it's like ah turn on the air conditioning and
then it's just oscillating it's going crazy right
around 72 because being a little bit below or a
little bit above you're just constantly reacting
to perturbations so these are oscillations that
happen in real Engineering Systems if we don't
design them correctly so one way to dampen
oscillations is to do something is to add
hysteresis and the idea behind hysteresis is that
if a perturbation happens I don't react right away
I'm actually just going to wait a while and see
let some more perturbations accumulate before I
react so if I'm at 71 whatever 71.8 I don't react
but then it went down to 71.6 and now I'm like H
it's not looking good and then it's 71 you know
4 and I'm like okay that was too much turn on the
heater so people add hysteresis into thermostats
so that we don't have these oscillations it's a
mechanism for dampening oscillations so our
hypothesis is that these systems also have
evolved to have hysteresis because these bridges
are constantly under perturbation there might be
wind the the things that they build on are often
sticks or branches they might move and you don't
want this system to constantly be adding or
removing ants all the time instead it should
wait as per perturbations accumulate and so Helen
made a model of it's called an accumulator model
where you have perturbations that accumulate
and then when enough accumulates the system
reacts and this was something we also observed
in the system uh ourselves so you can kind of
see it in the dots the dots Don't Follow The
Line exactly there's dots and then all of a
sudden there's a rise and there's some dots and
then there Rise and there dots we actually saw
that the system remodeled all of a sudden and
that a lot of times you could stretch and the
Ants would just allow themselves to be stretched
more and more and then all of a sudden they would
all react and something would happen and so this
is part of uh the basis for hisis system so it's
really exciting to discover that um even another
material property like hysteresis could be exist
exhibited by these self- assembling ants and
it does mean that we still actually then don't
fully understand the local hypothesis by which
uh by which these ants work so each time we do
these experiments we're still discovering new and
different kinds of rules okay so I've shown you
um uh two different systems that were inspired
by ants I briefly talked about the nerd herd as
being inspired by ants and I've shown you one
from our lab where robots are inspired by ants
so what kinds of future future applications are
there where we could use an ant inspired robot SW
or a robot Colony how about space ant colonies in
space so actually we could imagine not sending one
robot or two robots which is so fragile a decision
to make but instead sending groups of robots into
space to do tasks for us for so so some of you may
have heard of heard Talks by uh Professor Melanie
Moses here at University of New Mexico and um her
work has looked at she created something called
the uh swarm swarmathon the NASA swarmathon where
they considered groups of robots that kind of like
the nerd herd are finding elements in their
environment and bringing it together and this
competition involved many different uh minority
serving institutions designing different kinds of
algorithms and designing Hardware to to see how we
could eventually have robots on mars or on on the
moon doing exploration and bringing materials
back to a home base and I think this is one
exciting way in which uh an app colony is a really
great model because there's no leaders in charge
and there might be risks where individual robots
might get stuck or whay and we'd like the system
to be really robust the way ant colonies are so
that's one application in my group we've been
starting to look at another application thinking
about robots that are moving on a structure doing
inspection and this is work that we're doing with
Dr eriel ekla Who's at MIT she's the director of
the space exploration initiative uh she's a
very accomplished uh space person herself uh
and the idea is what if we could have future
space stations or spacecraft and have robots
moving on the structure constantly monitoring it
so looking for problems detecting problems maybe
even repairing the problems maybe even applying
materials onto the outside and so now instead of
climbing robots that climb over each other which
might be still a little bit hard for us to do we
have robots that are climbing over a structure
I like to think of this as arboreal ants that
live in trees and they're constantly moving
over this complex 3D structure in a symbiosis
with the trees so we could think of these robots
as being in a symbiosis um with the spacecraft
itself so with uh with Ariel we got to do this
great experiment we got to test some robots in
weightlessness and so I'm going to show you a
couple of videos from that just to to see what
that what that looks like so I'm going to start
with a little piece by Ariel this is a space
robots project to analyze the motion of robots on
the outside of spacecraft for future servicing and
maintenance operations so here you can see the
robot it's actually a really small robot this is
one of the robots that we're testing and it has a
magnets in it so it can move over metal structures
eventually we'd have to build more interesting
ways of moving but in this case we're T
ability now'll be one of
those Orient and this was only one of the robots
that we tested so here you can see this test and
some problems we also looked at some robots that
were inspired by Melinda's work so thinking about
inchworm like behavior and soft robots and our
goal was thinking about collaboration so wheel
robots can move really fast but maybe our climbing
robots could could cover gaps and so maybe the
robots could collaborate where one robot becomes
a bridge and the other robot climbs over it and
so we have now robots that act as Bridges and
other robots that act as moving around and so
it's really fun to see um this collaboration and
it was actually really interesting to be able to
design these kinds of experiments so I'll show you
just one more video because I think it's really
fun as to how how we actually get weightlessness
so obviously none of us really went to space we
have a train for anything like that instead we
went on an airplane and this is a company called
zerog G which uh is originally was formed to train
astronauts and the way it works is this airplane
shoots straight up into the sky almost and when
it goes up you a lot it's like a roller coaster
up you feel really heavy and when you come down
weight so here we are in the weightless phase uh
as you can see if you don't hold on to something
that's Julia for my La you might actually just fly
off and then when you go down you it's really
really heavy so we have to lie down and it's
really incredible how much weightlessness you can
get you get only 30 seconds of it at a time but
you can pretty much do anything so this is Bahar
uh Dr Bahar hagat from my from my lab she's now
a faculty member uh at University of kronan
in Netherlands and you'll see her again in a
minute and there you see Ariel again giving us the
thumbs up all right so of course we could think
of of inspection in space but we're also really
interested in whether we can use this on Earth so
imagine having multiple different kinds of robots
moving on a structure and uh and inspecting it so
this is uh a metal structure a sculpture outside
of our engineering Labs uh and this is uh as I
mentioned Dr uh Bahar hagat who's a faculty now um
and one of my uh former undergrad students Darren
and we're experimenting with swarms of these
robots to think about how they would move on this
structure how do they not get lost and remember
where they are and how can they use each other
as a way to become more powerful than each robot
is on its own and so here you can see we're just
trying to see and it can go underneath I wonder
if you can climb that these were we've now built
a bunch more of these robots they were originally
designed at MIT um and bahara is really scared
because we had borrowed these robots um so if they
broke we would have been in trouble but here you
can see they're actually pretty funny uh they
can they can escape our confines too so we have
a lot of escaping robots not escaping ants but
escaping robots all right so what can thousands
of individuals uh do together as a collective so
I hope I've shown you lots of examples of um how
remarkable natural collectives are because I
think that in the beginning I had no idea that
that ants could do the kinds of things they do
I always thought that was the realm of science
fiction movies like Big Hero 6 or something but
actually science is crazier than science fiction
sometimes um and I've also shown you a bunch
of robot examples where we hope that we can
make collectives that way but I think the most
amazing collective in all of this always is the
human Collective so of course I get to give this
talk but really all of the work that I've shown
is is a result of of science which is human uh
collective intelligence not just the groups that
I worked with but of course all of the scientists
who came before us setting up the situations and
the ideas from which we get to build further on
and hopefully create more scientists of our own so
this is my nerd herd um I've gotten to work with
some really great people from a lot of different
disciplines biologists Engineers mathematicians
physicists and I feel like it's really through
this interdisciplinary uh interaction something
that is so terrific about the Santa Fe Institute
this really interdisciplinary interaction that
we all get to literally uh become more than the
sum of our parts um so these are some of the
the terrific people that I've worked with and
as you can see this is the at the top left is
the original group that went off to uh spend
all this time in Panama so that's all I have
and thank you so much for uh this [Applause]
opportunity thank you so much
and now we'll open it up for
[Music]
questions so we um started out in the engineering
robotics building let's go across the campus to
the social science building is anybody looking at
those ants in terms of the demographics and their
role in those gaps the age the size the gender Etc
first of all all of the answer female so gender is
a clear one so all future societies are female um
yeah so so they're all she I try to use it so that
I think gender is something I hope to get that's
a longer conversation okay coming back to this
Army and are really interesting in that they have
uh different morphologies so you have these large
ants that are basically and some of them you might
have seen they had really big kind of tusks but
they basically are teeth and they will bite you
so they are the soldiers they're the protectors
then you have the middle workers who are often the
the majority of the bridge and then you have even
sort of minor workers and people still don't
quite understand what their role is they're
even smaller so you have first of all this this
real physical difference between them and so it
is known that at least in the army ants they do
play different roles but the rules are swappable
so we have seen uh soldier ants become Bridges
um we've often seen uh minor ants also become
part of a bridge so they're not the majority
they're they're usually just going to go past
or or stand around um but there is some there is
some flexibility and the roles that they have and
people have done very specific exam um things
to look at that flexibility um one of the the
the other thing you asked me was about age and I
think army ants are really hard to study because
they're nomadic so I would say like all of the
information on armads is kind of poor compared
to some other systems but in bees a lot is known
about age and they're definitely are different
roles that are played at different ages so for
example the young uh be there is some amount of
learning where the bees learn how to navigate and
find their way back to the nest and so the young
bees are often doing tasks inside the test whereas
the older bees are the ones that are going outside
finding food sources and coming back so you're
essentially sending you're more reliable people
are not going to get lost to come back and people
have studied a little bit of like that transition
like at what point does a young bee get to go out
and be uh a you know an experien uh individual
and so there's a lot of literature on trying to
understand how that transition happens with age
so I I feel like one of the interesting things
that I've learned from working with biologists is
that each system they study provides a different
opportunity to understand something about social
behavior even about our own evolution of social
behavior because sometimes these things are just
reflecting back to us things that we know we
do like fish move in her herds people move in
herds we also move like fish and bison we display
some of the exact same behaviors so there is a
connection there but each organism were only able
to ask certain questions so frustratingly we don't
have any example of collective where you know
everything instead you know something in here and
something in here and something in here so it is
kind of hard I wish we did know more about armads
but I I'm now convinced it's really hard um so I
can see why we may never we may never know those
answers my second question is how often do you
get bit but the first question is you showed a v a
video of a simulation the simulated robots forming
the Calver bridge I don't know if you programmed
them to preferentially form a horizontal bridge
but have you thought of the problem of deciding
whether to go horizontal or vertically down
or vertically up the way the answer can so
in that one it was really interesting the way
we the way we had envisioned that one and the
way Melinda ended up doing it is that there is a
goal so somewhere in the environment I've placed
a goal and the Ants or the robots can detect
that there's a goal and this is kind of how we
were thinking that Weaver ants do it is that they
they're often creating Bridges across branches or
different parts of leaves and then they actually
ratchet together so they even use those things as
pulling chain it's really quite remarkable but
often they're it's clear that they're trying to
get to something so if that thing is up then
it looks like a tower if the thing is across
then it looks like a bridge if the thing is
down it looks like a chain and so in in the
way she programmed it you just move the goal
around there isn't a sense in which they're
trying to make different structures they're just
trying to reach and it's like well I reached as
far as I could and then someone stepped on me so
I just stuck there and then it reached as far as
it could but then some someone stepped on it
but eventually you're still reaching and you
just have no way to get there so you kind of are
stuck anyways and so that's the kind of behavior
we were exploiting there does that answer the
question you and then your second question was
how many times we get bit so uh I think all of
us got bit at least once Helen probably got bit
a lot of times um but it is kind of painful they
they lock their jaws into into your finger but
they actually have no mechanism for unlocking so
it's kind of a onetime deal so you're stuck with
this thing that's pierced into you and no amount
of convincing it so you basically have to like
break its body off and then sit there and pry it
with pliers with the with the little tweezers I
mean it does kind of suck but this species is
actually really nice and they don't they don't
at best they bite you there's another species
that also like puts a little Venom into it so
like really stings and hurts in addition to being
bit you also have like a burning sensation for the
next day so luckily we were not working with that
species made it a lot easier but thank you for the
question um a lot of the experiments you've
performed have been on like creatures of lower
level intelligence um how do the patterns you've
observed apply to pod a pot of dolphins or like
a group of humans yeah it's a good question
because I think um I'm I'm always afraid to
call ants having lower intelligence because the
more they do the more crazy they seem to me so
I'm like not even sure anymore like maybe this
is all a simulation they're simulating us and
I had no idea what's going on um the ants are
pretty amazing but I think that when you go to
like bison right so like now you have a big or
even just large human groups maybe we do behave
the same way as ants but then when you go to
dolphins and you're talking about smaller numbers
of individuals there might just be very very I
think that there are very different techniques
by which a group will behave and so one sort of
idea might be that maybe group size in addition
to intelligence and language and all of the other
things that for example we assume that organisms
similar to us have we use language quite a bit
right so maybe size also matters so if I'm in a
small group I can do things like dolphins like
we could take roles we could even decide who's
going to be on which side we have gestures but
once I'm in a big group I can't actually do that
anymore I can't rely on that I might just say
like everybody out of the exit and then hope
everything goes well you know because it's no
longer language is no longer sufficient as a
mechanism for coordination so I have to admit
like I'm still trying to understand that exact
question that you you asked like where are those
fundamental when we see these different ways and
different strategies of working together is it
coming from the fact that certain organisms have
symbolic language and that makes a difference
or is it coming from the fact that it's a small
group and small groups behave differently but
I think that that that's really still an open
question so a lot of people debate it and make
abstract models it's a great area for study to
think about um the different groups strategies is
there a way to think about yeah how how different
groups work that's a great question thank you has
anyone conferred with or consulted with EO Wilson
on this the second question is why did these this
species evolve this way and have other ant species
also constructed structure like Harvest or ant
stone for example thank you so um uh actually of
course ear Wilson studied many of these different
species maybe not so much um the army ants but
another example of a highly evolved or complex
system are the leaf cutter ants and so there's
a great deal there's a beautiful book uh on that
with lots of gorgeous pictures by Wilson um and
so it seems that there are certain ants species
and I I don't want to misspeak here but I think
they call them usocial ones that have evolved
like really complicated social constructions so
leaf cutter ants for example will go up into into
trees and they cut leaves and they bring it back
but they have such a complex society they have
actually created an assembly line so there are
individuals who are cutting the leaves there are
individuals who are bringing the leaves there are
different individuals who are clearing the path
they even have ones that are Cutters they come
and they cut the grass so they make sure that the
path is nice and clean for the other individuals
to bring as much material back together and these
colonies have millions of individuals and they can
have these vast underground nests that people
have excavated that literally look like cities
you have like all of these Chambers connected by
these tunnels and so that's another case where
I'm like a little confused as to whether or not
ants have like a whole different Society going
down there that I don't know about um but it
is an open question like why did these certain
species evolve so much complexity um and so army
ants are example Weaver ants are another example
Weaver ants live in trees and they actually make
their nests by folding leaves over so they make
chains across different parts of the leaf and
then they actually kind of Ratchet together so
they basically are using the chains to pull the
parts of the leaves together and then they use
silk from their larvae to basically Stitch it or
basically glue it together that seems crazy I was
like that can't be true this this is a movie
somebody made this up um but somehow they've
evolved and they they live robust and trees this
way all the time so there are like these really
incredible examples that people study but why they
evolved to do this is still like I think a mystery
as far as I know but you probably ask uh some of
the the senior people like EO Wilson or or Naomi
Pierce um these kinds of questions I think it's
still it's still a mystery as to how Evolution
went through a path where there's so so incredibly
complex and an societies at least I don't know the
answer yeah I have a question here uh maybe
a little bit provocative but inanimate matter
uh also exhibits the same pattern you showed that
the funnel and then you look at Phase transitions
so some of the behaviors that large and I wouldn't
call them intelligent or unintelligent but I think
ants are lot similar to each other than humans
are so there's differentiation in intellect and
that creates complications so maybe the question I
have is do you see the same patterns that you the
patterns you're seeing reflect as you showed some
of the physical laws of you know inter you know
you can have molecules attracting and repulsing at
a certain distance and based on that they exhibit
patterns here you're translating them into code
right and this is no longer ANS just following
exactly yeah so it is similar it's inter inter and
interaction and same behaviors follow I think it
is a really interesting question whether if as
the number goes up you're kind of going further
and further into statistical mechanics right so I
think that debate is really very alive so people
think of um fish as self-propelled particles right
so it's it's a particle but it also has an energy
source which is slightly different so I've gotten
rid of conservation of energy so now maybe there
are other things that I can exhibit that wouldn't
be true for materials that are not actually eating
energy and using energy to produce actuation so
this concept that maybe there are active materials
and active materials can do more and so ants are
now an active material but I would say that humans
can also act as active materials so for example
people study the response of humans during panic
and even when there are large openings that we
should be able to get through we actually Jam and
managed to do things that cause more death than
would have happened if we just moved slowly and
got through this thing we're almost like the
rice that is just rushing through this funnel
and so people who are studying often human group
Behavior especially in situations of panic where
we're not going to use this heavy intellect in
order to assess we're just like Predator has
arrived move we perhaps behave more in these
fundamental modes that are available to us
from however we evolved from whatever organisms we
evolve that this just goes deeper as as a resource
that we have for working together and sometimes
that can lead to really good things like human
groups navigating together and moving across in
Caravans these long distances so much of that has
to do with giving up your own personal intellect
and desires and going with the group believing
in the navigation of whoever in the group was
deciding which way to go and so in that moment
we maybe are going back to behaving like fish
schools and actually benefiting from that so I
think both pathological States and beneficial
states that we experience as humans could come
from those things as well and I would say the ants
have personalities like people have looked at the
fact that different colonies have what they would
call culture some colonies are actually much more
aggressive at moving around and creating trails
and some are much more subdued and you can kind
of see this even passed on to their Pro so Deborah
Gordon's group at Stanford has really studied this
where they looked at these different um colonies
of harvester ants I hope I'm picking the right
ant I think it is the harvester ants and some
colonies were like creating lots of trails and
Gathering lots of food and other colonies had
smaller trails and had smaller colonies and
she did this 20 year experiment which is kind of
crazy but every year they would go out and they
would catalog all of the colonies and look at
the genetic relationship so which were the new
colonies and it turned out that the one that wins
in 20 years is not the one who was aggressively
eating food and so that was like a major surprise
that in fact like the short-term activity which
many people were interpreting as success and the
long-term success as in how many colonies are
from your genetic material were not necessarily
correlated so I think we still like don't have so
many different ways in which we don't understand
the relationship between individuals and then
culture and then multiple cultures and then the
impact that has on evolutionary success so it
means that we scientists can never be out of a
job so I'm good with that um as I was watching
the videos I didn't notice any ants falling um and
I'm curious if the army ants have a no ant Left
Behind policy but but in all seriousness um I was
curious if there are different species of swarms
that have uh where where individuals sacrifice
themselves for the greater good yeah so so army
ants are really good climbing so it's actually
kind of they just don't fall off of anything
unless you kick them off or you coat it with like
really serious it's very hard to contain them in
any which way they just get out of everything
so um they we don't no so one of the things
that would happen during this experiment is that
you could sometimes um mess up and so you you did
something drastic and the Ants didn't like it so
they take a U-turn and they just like leave your
apparatus and you're there trying to coax them
back with like a water bottle we squirt them so
it's just like you squirt a dog to tell it that's
doing the wrong thing we're scorting the ants but
they still leave but when they leave now there's
no Trail so you can see these ants like wandering
trying to figure out how to get back home and my
presumption is that a bunch of them get lost but
there's just millions of them so they're migrating
they're moving in different places um and so I I
would say like getting there's definitely ants
Left Behind there's definitely not No Child Left
Behind uh policy um but the soldiers can and do
sacrifice themselves so in as I was explaining
when they bite that's kind of the end they can't
actually unclasp their jaws so that's sort of a a
fatal choice to bite as opposed to just posture
and like scare everyone off so when they raid
or they get raided um they do end up sacrificing
soldiers and so that is an example where you know
some of them are are essentially you know maybe
less likely to live as long as the other ants
again we don't I don't think we know enough about
army ants but they're probably other species where
they know more about whether you see very active
forms of uh sacrificing and I guess the the way
I would think about it is that ants are clonally
related so unlike a fish school where each fish
actually has a different genetic code ants are
practically like cells so people think of an ant
colony often as being a collection of cells and we
know that cells in our body will die um that you
have sort of apoptose is where cells actively uh
die in order to create some structure or in order
to fix some infection and that's fine because all
of the other cells are there the organism is fine
even if some of your cells die that's perfectly
fine so an an colony and some ways is closer to
an organism with cells so it would be not that
surprising to have ants sacrifice themselves
because actually they're just genetically
identical to a lot of the others and so that's an
okay strategy evolutionarily speaking I hope that
my biologist colleagues agree with what I'm saying
I realize all of this I'm sort of channeling
the things that I've learned from them but
there could be errors in my in my understanding
so I hope you'll take this all with a grain of
salt we got one more question back here oh I
have one more all right sorry I didn't mean to
interrupt I was curious about um if you witnessed
any reward incentives in the ants behavior and if
within the robotics section of this you would
want to incentivize teamwork so if one robot
could complete a task by itself it would be
programmed to wait until it would work with a
cooperator now that's a really interesting
question and I think that maybe because in
this system we were so focused on ants that sort
of cooperate by Design we weren't thinking of
incentives per se but even for the ants there
are incentives so for example um although I
showed it as very simply as this Trail and and
individuals forming Bridges there's actually ants
going in both directions in One Direction there
ants that are going towards the food source and
in the other directions there are ants coming
back that are carrying the food source and one
of the things we found is that those carrying
the food source never cooperate in the bridge
they actually only cross the bridge so they
are way too valuable uh they're holding like
the food of the colony and they're trying to
get it as fast as possible uh to the nest so
they're just waiting for other people to do
the teamwork of making the ridge so you could
argue that even in that system where there
isn't explicit an incentive there is kind of
an incentive if you if you have food then you are
incentivized to go back to the nest as quickly as
possible and it is not you are not a good team
member if you're going to sit in a bridge with
the food uh and keep it there you need to just
be hurrying on whereas if you're not carrying
food and you're going to get food well maybe you
should first be willing to sacrifice your time
and life to be this bridge so that others with
food can can get the food fast and that that's
that's the teamwork that is incentivized for you
but I haven't done a system where we looked more
at maybe going back to the human model where
individuals have really individual goals and
so by Nature they're not automatically cooperating
they're automatically doing whatever they need to
do and that only in certain situations they're
needs to be an incentive to work as a team and
I I don't have a I it's I guess it's something
I haven't actually worked on but there are other
people in robotics who have worked on that and
one of the ways that they've worked on this is
when people from different Labs bring robots
together so now you contributed some robots
I contributed some robots and the robots are
all programmed slightly differently they work
on certain principles but we would still like
the robots to work together and so now there
has to be some sort of notion of teamwork that is
separate from how the robots themselves have been
Pro programmed to ask and even so you might even
have robots cooperating with humans and now again
you might need to have some sort of notion of
incentives and teamwork explicitly programmed into
the robots so there are several faculty who are
working on those kinds of areas as well it's just
not an area that I know that well thank you so
much have a wonderful evening all right thank you
everyone